au couteau tu t'es folle et de ses
proches comme station équipée comme kaba
commenté pavin rêve tintaya mêmes causes
bancaire dans son maloya avec son groupe
solide au caire sans la route sans
résignation les opales l'amour pour son
pays
nous se retrouve à l'hyper la casca
barre
[Musique]
bonjour
endroit au monde merci tintin qu'il ya
goûté à la casse kaba conseil représente
les la peau pour moi c'est un rêve tous
à nous viva nous arrive à nous comme le
d'aviva nous ont fait l'entourage
souhaité nous mêmes c'est créole sais
comment c'est mon jeu 3 et pense qu'on
pense qu'on me l'a toujours pensé et si
on était content quand ils ont été en
france est parasitée par les affaires
c'est la hausse il inspire vous pouvez
la musique commence jamais pour comment
s'écrit bonne texte oui en fin de compte
à moins d'un moins grand fan daniel et
car aux affaires mais plutôt nous à
l'extérieur
webroot au sommet en fin de compte en
cause
[Musique]
sous
amen
accor
[Musique]
maloya fally moderne s'il peut dire ça
comme ça
ou comment décrire l'esprit tentant
mi-comique rallye comme il fut eli lilly
en maloya malien pourrait miser avec
bandaï a rappelé celui auquel s'est pas
seulement terrain puisqu'ils musicale 11
monde s'aimait pas de musiciens effet
c'est banal fait donc sa du nokia s'est
auto group si ces deux textes sont
écrits toute l'inspiration quand j'écris
cette date il ya moins de l'oralité même
pas guillon panaf et m'écoutent bonpé de
moins de cause il en fait mes
questionnements que des chansons à mon
band qu'on vous raconte tout bon qui
sait nous demandent aux bonnes âmes en
soufflant à l'origine mais c'est un foot
on sent l'amour petit et bien on n'est
pas là pour embêter on n'est pas là pour
oser face à ça c'est mon bonbon imai pas
le créole dire ça nous a sa base électro
analphabètes ils firent pas livre il
fait par fond de guerre met à profit
tous c'est dans ce qu'elle m'aime c'est
une plante me trouve la lumière
d'autres cas dans 2/3 causées qui nous
donne est-ce que nous là l'impression
que ça cause rebelles
mais si la rébellion pas seulement
compter toutes sortes
c'est la rébellion aussi contre lui ni
moi mais c'est monté mauricien victimes
et nous le fruit d'un abomination et le
fruit a fait mais cela fait aussi la
plus avec quoi d'un stage de son
histoire et la pose d'un tapis métisse
vivant son mari de monique conceptualise
bonne affaire vivent ensemble la
tolérance c'est me parle du ps à pau en
fin de compte n'est pas un concept des
îles vanille commence qu'est ce que
c'est de là qu'on n'entraîne pas tout
rêve le rêve donc par là nous depuis les
débuts oui mais pour être mon rêve et
des fois nous nous rendons nous compte
la forêt où ça se lit locales savent à
soliloquer s'emmène à nous dans l'avenir
à moins bien mais nous il me fut montant
du cautionnement quel message principal
quelles paroles important peau
comment s'est il est capable
nul n'est capable nous les obligeons les
gaillards et il n'a pas besoin ou pas
besoin plus que ça merci